nous sommes au plein coeur de la vallée
de chevreuse à la maison de
l'écomobilité à saint rémy les chevreuse
c'est ici que l'on peut emprunter la
vélo ceni un itinéraire cyclable de 450
kilomètres qui relie le mont saint
michel à notre dame de paris
nous allons tester pour vous un tronçon
de huit kilomètres c'est parti avec moi
la délégation de la vélo s'est mis
quelques élus et des représentants du
club des villes et territoires cyclables
ils vont parcourir l'avait losséni en
entier pour promouvoir cet itinéraire
vélo pour ce tronçon nous partons de
saint rémy les chevreuse direction
choisel est à peine 200 mètres parcourus
nous empruntons une piste cyclable c'est
plutôt agréable de ne pas croiser deux
voitures
[Musique]
voilà ça fait 3 km que je roule ici on
peut voir de nombreux paysages donc
derrière moi le château de la madeleine
à chevreuse notre périple se poursuit
sur l'itinéraire de la vélo ceni nous
alternons entre pistes et bandes
cyclables on a fait quasiment la moitié
cap km 4 km 5
il ya des petits dénivelés des fois mais
avec le vélo électrique est plutôt sympa
arrivé à choisel l'occasion de faire une
halte à l'auberge des trois hameaux et
de discuter avec une représentante de la
ville au cynisme on april trajet de la
ville hosni pour organiser un voyage de
cinq jours
aujourd'hui c'est notre deuxième journée
et on met en valeur en fait plein
d'initiatives vélo dont l'avait losséni
en filigrane on reprend le vélo
changement de vitesse quelques côte à
monter pour arriver à la ferté un hameau
de choisel devant nous des maisons de
pierre caractéristiques de ce village
quelques kilomètres encore et au loin
notre destination
le château de breteuil voilà j'ai fini
moi mon parcours des 8 km je me suis
arrêté au château de breteuil que vous
pouvez voir derrière moi sinon vous
pouvez continuer direction rambouillet
[Musique]